five ways you can keep your man and keep your man happy
follow these five things
if you wanna be a good wife or girlfriend to your partner
this ensures your man is happy
and it'll help prevent your man from cheating
number one always have food ready on the table
okay food really is the way that a man's heart
okay he's not gonna be going to a drive thru or restaurant
where he can talk to a cute girl behind the register or have a girl serve him
no that should be your duty
men connect food with happiness
so always, always remember to make sure he's fed
No 2 show affection.
take initiative,
hug him, kiss him,
show him everyday how happy he really makes you!
men are big on affection
they wanna feel special,
just like we do.
if you're not doing this
he's gonna be looking for elsewhere
he shouldn't have to beg for affection
or beg to have his needs met as a man
No. 3 clean for him
clean the house,
do his laundry,
always make sure his clothes are cleaned.
and don't get annoyed with him because he needs help to do his laundry.
if it’s easy for you,
but hard for him.
why don't you just help him out?
make sure the house is tidy as well.
a man is more likely to want to come home to you,
or stay home if the house is tidy and clean.
he'll appreciate this
and not only that
why would he ever leave a good woman who takes care of them?
No. 4 do not bicker or complain to him.
men do not have a taste for drama.
so leave that for your girlfriends.
he wants to relax when he gets home,
so if you're always complaining or bickering at him to do something,
he's not gonna feel like the man of the house.
and guess what he'll be looking outside of your house to feel like the man.
No. 5 be his peace.
you should be the one that where he gets home,
you melt his stress away.
simply understand his needs and provide him with such.
if he needs to relax or unwind,
let him. This ensures
he won't be wandering off
looking for other girls to be his peace.
you be his peace,
and that will make him happy!
So always make sure he's never hungry,
show him affection,
keep the house tidy,
make sure his needs are met,
and be his peace.
it's that simple.
and you'll be able to keep your man happy